the first thing I'd like you to try is
play so once you press that this is what
appear it's really simple let me give
you an easy example let's have a go I'd
say this one okay so this is the second
one here okay I hope you can see that so
just like I've got up on my board right
this is a balanced system you've got two
things there and well one is exactly
equal to the other so if that green
heart is seven what must the purple
diamond bin must also be seven well oops
i'm going to put five wait what happened
why is my green heart lower because it's
the evidence it's heavier right so I
need to try again if I put 800 don't
wear again so now if I put in seven and
you submit and then it gives you some
stars hooray ok so now you come back and
I'm going to show you a tricky one let's
try it this one hold on a second ok now
some of you may be thinking oh I think
it's for how can we logic that out well
watch this watch watch watch watch watch
if I put my finger on the top thing it's
a mobile right like a spinning mobile
right if I put it and drag it out watch
what happens BAM now what is that we
have a word for this it starts with a
when you don't know what numbers are
what is it this is algebra right look
look look these are just labels we use
letters because these I don't carry
color pencils with me ok on a card draw
hearts nicely but that's algebra yeah
then labels for numbers watch this
remember their balance both sides look
I've got an extra heart there on the
left-hand side see daddy I don't really
want so i'm going to pick that up and
pull one out of both sides did you see
that look I took one out from both sides
because I got to keep things balanced so
if a heart is worth two and I've got two
of them there on the right hand side
right so that's how you can know that
this trapezium thing is done ok now one
more thing I need to show you and then
you can just go for it ok have a look at
this one
see that number at the top that number
of the top means that's how heavy the
whole thing is sometimes you'll see that
number and you need to know what do you
reckon for the blue moon doesn't make
sense does it all add up to eight you
better does there are stars okay so I
want you to go back to that puzzle menu
if you feel like all these explore ones
too easy try a puzzler or a master one
and there's lots of pages you can flick
through go for it